So as mentioned, I am Michelle Ware-Ivy, and I am, okay, there we go.
I am Michelle Ware-Ivy, and I am currently the founder of the Malcolm Orlando Ivy Foundation.
And joining us today is to be able to talk about the value of early screening.
I do want to go ahead and say a big, special thank you.
Thank you to Dr. Sandra Mazzoni.
She has been excellent in caring for my dear husband, Malcolm Ivy, and she's always been
quite innovative in thinking about, again, the patient needs and the patient care.
So Dr. Mazzoni, thank you.
I stand before you here as a surviving care partner to my husband.
He was first diagnosed with multiple myeloma in 2020.
And what you see here on this screen is a brief snippet of a
article that was published by my company, Thermoficia Scientific,
that really talked about, again, turning this loss into legacy.
And what is a big part for me on this is being able to be that voice in order to, again,
amplify the early screening process that exists for multiple myeloma.
There isn't one, as you all know quite well.
So why does this matter?
This matters because there is a critical unmet need within our community.
And I'm so happy and encouraged to hear about, you know, what we're doing in the community space.
But these are data that you know quite well.
These are, again, for 2026, projected by the American Cancer Society as to the number of
patients newly diagnosed with multiple myeloma.
And then, of course, the deadly, devastating act of the mortality rate.
And with this, we see a significant unmet need within the high-risk community.
And this is where we want to make a difference as to having a earlier screening process,
such as we do for colon cancer and breast cancer, to really be able to make a difference.
Because again, this really exists.
And it's personally, for me, created an impact.
So my personal story here is my dear husband, he was a father, he was a grandfather, and
he was a baby brother.
And we lived with this silent condition for years without knowing.
He was very active and he had a balanced diet, but somehow we miss multiple myeloma with
signs and symptoms because we simply did not know about it.
So here takes us through the trajectory of being able to see all of the events that happened
that led up to that emergency room visit that diagnosed him at a stage three.
Again, I remain grateful.
To our diagnostic companies that they are able to identify for us now as to finding
out about MGUS earlier.
So we're able to be able to detect for multiple myeloma, but also to J&J that then now there
is that Dazalexa could be used for smothering multiple myeloma.
So that way it will help delay the time of getting into full-blown multiple myeloma.
And what you see here again, really uncovers the fact of missing multiple myeloma.
So it's very important that we understand this condition and why early screening is
going to be quite important to us.
And one of the key ways that I, you know, continue to amplify voice and be a voice for
the voiceless is through Dr. Giselle Cook.
I am a citizen scientist within her research that she's doing study to have that early
screening process at Mayo Clinic.
She's doing this and not only just screening, but she's providing education to the community,
building that health care system.
And she's doing this and not only just screening, but she's providing education to the community,
So one person is able to know about it and they extend the knowledge to other people.
So again, trying to close that gap of that unmet need in order to be able to diagnose
and find out about this much earlier.
And finally here, as far as another opportunity for bridging the gap, I, you know, stand before
you.
I've been recently to Capitol Hill, being able to share again, my story, requesting
for prevention.
Requesting for early detection and being able to be in the community with community
physicians, and then our community to be able to amplify educational and build health
literacy.
And then most importantly here, not a snapshot on the chart is being part of the Ash patient
collaborative, where I'm able to share my voice to ensure that when we think about research
and when we think about clinical trials, that we're making it inclusive, that all patients,
all lives are thought about, all patients are able to receive these treatments and being
able again, to have that better access for care.
So in closing, I thank you, I thank you for the work that you're doing.
I know there's still a lot to be done and, you know, I'm here to partner with you.
One of us trying to find and be able to diagnose multiple myeloma much early.
And this shows the progress that we're making in partnership with a community in partnership
with Well-Extablished.
Patient Advocacy Group in order to help amplify the voices.
So in regard to creating a value, my final word is, you know, again, being able to detect
this earlier.
So once we have it detected earlier, there are treatments, as you well know, that will
be able to sustain lives longer and then potentially save lives.
So thank you for your time.